was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut heute sind wir tatsächlich
ein bisschen weit weg war das muss aber
leider auch sein weil ich habe neue
amazon retouren gekauft und ich glaube
heute sind es wirklich ausnahmsweise ich
kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass wir
mal so und so benner sachen hatten von
amazon das weiße wald immer so ganz okay
aber so wirklich dass ich jetzt mal mit
sagt nachbar krank das hat sich gelohnt
wie zb weil andere und paket von letzter
woche leute wenn ihr dieses video und
nicht gesehen habt das unbedingt an die
arbeit zu machen habe ich auch vom
großhändler malt er ist auf jeden fall
da ganz gut dabei und dem buch immer
kurz an weil ich wollte noch etwas
fragen auch für euch und für mich für
die sich wissen dass ich es grad der hat
mir die palette palette ist es ist an
sich eher eine kiste bier verkauft ich
habe ihnen gesagt no pass auf ich möchte
mal geile amazon retouren ganzen
mehrwert machen und da bin ich jetzt
noch mal hin gedüst jetzt wirklich noch
mal von dem hören bevor ich das auf
mache was ist denn da so drin
[Musik]
also es ist nicht nur amazon
möchten immer ganz gerne sich kartons
haben wir den katheter fragen kann und
hörst du dementsprechend hier optimal
weil er einfach sehr viele artikel drin
sind da hast du ja hass gewisser
haushaltsgeräte klein also alles kleine
artikel
bei artikel aber sehr viel stärker wahr
elektronik
ich bin mir sicher
was hab ich bezahlt 150 euro da können
wir nicht mehr kann und
[Musik]
das ist auch ich muss sagen die kiste
ist ganz schön schwer
ich denke auf jeden fall die daumen ich
hab dich er selber nicht reingeschaut
ich weiß nicht du kannst deine
überraschungskiste weiß ja das war der
einkaufspreis ja das war von mir
und ich dir wirklich zusammen das sind
allesamt mir gut ich danke dir wenn nur
quatsch drin ist dann hoch wie die hier
zwar noch einmal alles
gut alles gut machen wir schon ich danke
dir wir sehen uns nur ein job also die
150 euro die ich dafür bezahlt habt sind
wirklich ein sehr sehr guter preis
hoffen was mag bin gespannt ob sich
lohnen wird let's go ich hab so angst
vor diesem paket ich konnte es nicht
alleine juckt es ist so schwer ist
leider ein gutes zeichen dass ich das
noch irgendwie hochbau leute ich schwöre
dieses ding wie so viel wie ich ohne
witz
ich hätte es echt sehr gerne mal gewogen
aber ohne witz das liegt safe 60 kilo
also nicht ganz so schwer wie ich 60
kilo kann auch nicht jeder so mal eben
hier auf dem tisch tragen
ja ich bin echt mal gespannt ich kann es
gar nicht einschätzen ihr habt zwar
gehört vom wo es ist nicht eine
elektrische zahnbürste
es ist nicht alles von amazon aber
vieles das steht zb wahrscheinlich nicht
ich hasse diese dinger fangen wir mal
mit dem ersten produkt anti haben wir
ein max bögl eisen die dinger gibt es
glaube ich beim netto oder so milben
hans staub server bügeleisen also ist
halt fast das gleiche auch noch okay das
ist einen handstaubsauger den schenke
ich meiner oma weil ihrer ist sondern
woche kambodscha das trifft sich
eigentlich ganz gut was guckst du hast
keine ahnung da wird sicherlich 40 euro
kosten oder sagen wir 35 hiermit machen
wir weiter langweilig led dinger hier
ich habe so eine app damit kann ich
jedes einzelne produkt einscannen und
euch direkt sagen was das kostet na
super das ist leider nicht in der
datenbank drin wird man schätzen 10 euro
weiter geht's was ist das der
bauchmuskel roller
fitnessgeräte kennt man ja kann man
auspacken und sich dann einmal über den
boden rollen damit hat und unter
und wieder das ist echt schwieriger als
genug
alter und bei den linken ist sogar ein
counter mit nach vorne und auf dem stand
vor
[Musik]
ich hab's 24 euro und 90 leuten und muss
ja auch sagen mittlerweile habe ich
schon erfahrung was das angeht und ich
kann euch sagen das ganze zeug hier drin
hat es also wenn ich das jetzt zu sehen
der tat safe alles zusammen und werk von
mindestens 500 euro oder wahrscheinlich
sogar 700 euro was zum beispiel als
nächstes eine elektronische zahnbürste
und wir haben ja nicht nur eine
zahnbürste wäre mir sein ganzes kit 25
euro je anteil gerechnet aber wo dein
alter das will ich euch direkt zeigen
leute diese dinger sind doch gerade mega
im trend massage pistole vier aufsätze
für unterschiedliche muskelgruppen er
ich wollte so etwas schon immer mal
testen das probieren wir direkt mal aus
ich habe das ding immer mit nach hause
genommen hier unsere wunderbare massage
pistole und die machen wir jetzt mal
auch also hier zack da kommt dann in so
einem navi tal case und so sieht das
schon aus bin mal gespannt ich hoffe
dies aufgeladen wir haben ein ladekabel
dabei das wirkt ein bisschen bilder
obwohl es ja es geht noch und dann hier
diese massage gang das ist ja glaube ich
so der standard aufsatz der kommt dann
hier drauf und haben wir hier noch
andere aufsetzen kann man wahrscheinlich
auch alle rein machen
hier gibt es auch sogar verschiedene
stufen du für zwei
kann man das eigentlich war ja alles
schon lightbody hat auf jeden fall schon
papa ich weiß halt nicht ob man das bei
sich selber machen soll ist halt schon
glaube ich entspannen wenn das jemand
bei einem macht muss man es nicht selber
machen oder weil es hier immer so muss
ich sagen schon eine geile erfindung
dieser massage kann das ringen kostet
140 euro und ich sehe aktuell extrem
viel influenza werbung mit diesen ganzen
massage ganz wichtiger tipp lasst euch
nicht verarschen weil die teile guckt
beim internet gibt niemals 150 euro
dafür aus klar die qualität mag kann es
gut sein aber an sich das was ich
gesehen habe es gibt auch alles wird
deutlich weniger im internet zu kaufen
ohne diese komische jim irgendwas brand
da drauf und ihr habt ja gesehen die da
tut's auch gut machen wir weiter davon
haben wir glaube ich zwei hat ist nun
das conditioning fan chinesischer
luftreiniger in client noch so ein
bauchmuskel trainingsgerät hat hat
allerdings nicht sondern kommen werde
carla bruni werse holzständer für
kopfhörer okay keine ahnung ob ich da
habe ich zwei stück von einer christel
26 euro haben also wir haben ja an liegt
die 150 haben wir ja schon hand ist aber
einige zahlen müsste leute schaut euch
mal diese zahl bislang nicht irgend ein
bisschen benutzt aus da sind auch schon
soko a das kann man ja keinem antun
kommt in müll ach so genau hier haben
wir dann auch schon den zweiten lüfter
und aston geil
metalldetektor womit teil dick metall
deck mit
metalldetektoren sind schon teuer soweit
ich weiss tolle leute selbst diese
dinger kosten zwischen 35 und 55 euro
und davon haben wir gleich zwei läuft
eigentlich muss ich sagen mir ist
eigentlich auch wichtig dass ich das
nicht nur aus pappe und hin und wieder
mal testet oder auch irgendwie einen
kleinen mehrwert bietet vielleicht schon
einblick darin gebe die ziehe ich davon
verkauft bekommen und wie lange das
dauert weil sonst muss ich auch sagen
finde ich das auf dauer ein bisschen
länger ich weiß die meisten von euch
feiern dass wir nicht einfach retouren
kauf und die auspacke warum auch immer
aber ich finds oft auch ein bisschen
länger also irgendwie muss ich mir da
was einfallen lassen in diffusor aufgabe
da kann man so wasser rein machen das
war ein bisschen ätherische öle dann
tust du das ding wasserdampf in eine
wohnung kostet circa 20 euro so
weitergeht hier haben wir noch ein so
augen fernglas alter gaul woche
früher habe ich immer mit ferngläsern
will beobachtet heute werde ich mit
können der samtigen beobachten das kommt
richtig in seiner verpackung hier geil
geil geil hier muss ich sagen das ist
glaube ich das ist ein krankes fernglas
das ist geisteskrank ist anlass also
hiermit kannst du auch wenn du schon
älter bist wieder hd sehen ob
meine nachbarin spaß habe keine machbare
aber ich muss sagen geiles fernglas zu
25 euro da habe ich jetzt einmal mehr
gerichte daher gut dann war das ja gar
nicht so schlimm dass ich einmal
aufgerissen habe wir haben ja echt auch
ein paar unbrauchbare kleine kleinteile
die jetzt nicht viel wert sind wie
dieses ding hier zum beispiel das tier
seiner smart watch wobei die vielleicht
sogar es wert sein kann die ist nämlich
von schauen ja jetzt nicht mehr ich will
euch diese ganzen kleinen teile gar
nicht unbedingt alle zeigen und das ist
ja auch irgendwie schade immer wenn es
um touren sind du gehst damit so als
wärs ja eigentlich scheißegal so darf es
allerdings nicht sein elektronische
zigarette halter okay das muss ich
direkt beim eine freundesgruppe schicken
das habe ich schneller weg als wir
gucken können 36 euro also jetzt nicht
so viel aber immerhin ok ich möchte
jetzt gerne mal hier zu den größeren
sachen kommen wo ich auch weiß was ist
fester und eintracht deswegen jetzt weiß
ich auch warum das so schwer ist hier
unten ist nämlich den handset die haben
wir noch eine led-lampe und jetzt passt
mal auf war der boom bang einfach ein
metalldetektor eigentlich das ding ganz
schön leicht das macht mir sorgen neu
verpackt somit teil detektoren die sind
doch gar nicht mal so günstig oder die
sind doch schon ein bisschen teurer aber
ich weiß nicht ob ich denn jetzt auch
machen soll ich würde gern damit auf
schatzsuche gehen aber irgendwie habe
ich keinen bock und deswegen draußen
auch er war es mit teil der tectura hier
habe ich noch hey was also ich hab jetzt
gedacht so metalldetektoren sind richtig
teuer aber der kostet mal 50 euro die
kleinteile taschenrechner habe ich hier
noch das lasse ich alles mal hier drin
und pulsmesser von beurer deutsche marke
german standards
also damit habe ich jetzt nicht
gerechnet aber hier kosten vier stück
375 euro und das ist mengenrabatt ich
habe nur ein weiß ich nicht 90 95 und
alleine zum kleinen unscheinbaren
produkte vor nicht gar keine ahnung habe
habe ich fast alles wieder raus haben
wir noch irgendwie so ein fußball ihrer
aber von chinesischen marke dann auch
hier in rasierer mit einigen aufsetzen
kostet ca 40 euro also wir sind ziemlich
viele produkte von diesem jahr ist drin
aber nah war es ist glaube ich mit
qualität das ist denke ich mal sonne
random amazon brand das ist auf jeden
fall ein schminkspiegel so dann haben
wir hier noch sachen einmal 5 1
technology kommt bei hier streaming
setup mikrofon und manche leute mit so
einem mikrofonarm also das ist so ein
ganzes set kostet neu 60 euro dann haben
wir hier noch eine navarre
nudeln nudeln trockener sollte man hier
nudeln drauflegen oder was sowas gibt ja
die unnötig oder wer benutzen so was
jetzt kommt das größte jedem 10 ist
jetzt auch so schwer
sorry handelsstadt dms germany handels
kurzhanteln wie fühlt 30 kilo eigentlich
könnte ich das mal eben auspacken und
hier manchmal im büro dann so ich fühle
mich hier manchmal ein bisschen
unausgelastet
und ich habe mir hier mal eben nur sechs
kilogramm langhantel zusammengebastelt
ich weiß nicht wie viel am ende alles
zusammen wert ist ich werde zu berechnen
ansonsten mache ich jetzt mein training
und wir hören uns dann morgen früh noch
mal die heute wieder mittlerweile den
nächsten tag endlich mal wieder schönes
daraus ein strahlend blauer himmel so
lässt sie sich da raushalten und ich
habe in der zwischenzeit alles mal ein
bisschen geordnet und sortiert und bin
zum fazit gekommen alles zusammen was
ihr hier und da hinten im raum haben hat
einen gesamtwert von mindestens 600 euro
also wirklich realistische preise immer
alles los wird aber das ist manchmal gar
nicht so leicht kennt der ein absoluter
banker war das jetzt nicht aber es war
schon sehr sehr sehr gut und ich bin mal
gespannt was man da so rausholen kann
dass wir sehr gerne noch nach oben da
wenn ich weiterhin retouren restposten
kaufen soll die auspacken soll zu
schauen was kann man also finden was
kann man damit verdienen es kommen aber
auch weiterhin andere projekt hier auf
dem kanal das ist ganz ganz wichtig zu
sagen und wir sehen uns demnächst wieder
drei leute aber wer neues j